listen i love this the show
um first three episodes of season two
are fantastic one of the things that i
especially love
is that every episode has a crazy what
the [ __ ] moment
something that like leaves your jaw on
the ground how much do you guys know
about
what's gonna happen before you're
getting the scripts and or are you just
reading it on the page for the first
time
uh season one for example
we we knew we had six episodes in
advance well no four
in advance so we really knew we had a
really good lead on what was coming
season two was not quite quite the same
but we were still
a couple of episodes ahead i think we
had a rough idea of what was coming
uh and at the at the beginning of every
season of each season so far eric set
everyone down and going this is what's
happening with your character and yada
yada so
that was i don't know for aya coming in
uh what it was like but
pretty good for us eric sort of broke
down the season for me before we started
shooting and went over like the big plot
points that happen
um uh some things he was like are you
comfortable with this here's what we're
thinking about this
and we wrote this this is really you
know where we want to go with this
um but then yeah you we read them sort
of
chunks at a time as we went later and
sort of got specifics but
it's nice to have it broken down for you
too so you know where you're
headed because sometimes especially like
network tv you're getting scripts like
the week of and you are like wow i would
have maybe done this differently had i
known this was happening next because
they're still writing but they're
basically written by the time we get
there i you have i don't want to get
into spoilers but
i'm going to say you have some
interesting dialogue from what i've seen
in season two um what is it like on set
delivering this interesting dialogue
uh i would say that uh as you can
imagine it's super uncomfortable
um but it's also uh you know
i i don't we don't live in a in a
perfect world of
um you know roses and daisies all the
time i i
if we're trying to comment on something
the only way
to do that is to give some sort of
accurate representation in the
heightened world that we're in
so uh i always felt like it was
necessary and that sort of
uh that sort of language uh
exists in this world and in our world
as well and and those are things that
should be talked about
uh as audience members um i think that
starting the conversation about that as
long as it's not glorifying in a way
that feels
um exploitative
and i hopefully i think we walked the
line of being able to
say things uh in a way that felt real
and jarring and upsetting and shocking
but also
um not exploitative
from what i've seen i completely think
you guys have
done it very well um uh anthony uh i
love your performance as homelander uh i
i think uh
you know if you look online i think it's
a universal thing everyone just
uh loves your work on it i'm curious
what is it like
flipping the switch and becoming the
megalomaniac and is it something that
like you can just turn on are you sort
of revving the engine before you stand
on set
um yeah i was gonna i i'm just
be myself you you know i do want to take
over the world and
kill people now um
it's funny it's it's it's you know i
i don't want to sound like a psycho but
i i enjoy it
it's just fun because it's the kind of
character that you never get
you get to do things on set not
literally do them but you get to say
things and do things you know those
i mean you're just talking about the the
dialogue
that um the interesting dialogue that
uh i had to deliver and you know
i kind of relish that
the dark side i love it i love the
opportunity to say and do these things
that i would
never say and do in real life and nobody
would unless
you're crazy um so in terms of
in terms of becoming that it's for me
it's it's it's a relatively simple thing
you just
you you know what's required in the
scene and throw yourself into it and
uh you know we're lucky we've got we got
a boss that wants options so we give
lots of different options up
options on each tank and um
and then they select and they edit and
uh take the bits they want and the bits
they don't so
it's uh it's a very collaborative show
and a very collaborative process so
they we're just a piece of that jigsaw
in season two the there was an extra
three days of production on every
episode
um and i i'm not sure if you knew that
you had extra time
uh with season two um can you talk about
how that
played into making the season better if
you will or
what that added to the show having that
extra time
i'm going to be honest it's a it's a
beast of a show
it is uh the productions expanded and
took over another couple of studios last
year
and in season two uh so
that time was spent you know as
as shows develop the ideas
um the characters get deeper and the
ideas around character and story get
deeper but the show did expand as well
and
some of the set pieces got a bit bigger
you know we had a rather large whale
uh built uh and things like that so you
know the
the the sequences that we have i mean i
cash has some uh pretty incredible
sequences coming up later in the season
that i'm not going to spoil but
they they they're very time consuming
and very difficult and she can
she can speak more on those but but uh
yeah i mean
whatever you know film is greedy and it
will
chew up all the time you've got
yeah i definitely i was gonna say i
definitely want to hear about these
things
oh i was just gonna say you know i i
came really off a show that we finished
uh we'd do an episode in four and a half
days
so it's a very different kind of show to
be on the boys where
we do that not only are there such long
shoot uh schedules just in terms of the
days per episode
but then there's second unit going that
will go on
later to catch up because even with the
extra time it's almost
impossible to get everything that needs
to get done done
because it's such a big show i mean like
you this when i watched the boys season
one i was like it's like a movie i mean
it's so cinematic and there's huge
camera moves and set pieces and massive
amounts of extras i mean it's a
superhero show so it's what's needed so
it's a very different way of working so
i would even work
i mean we would there's like almost all
of episode six i think we shot
way after we finished this like after we
finished the season
because everything had to get pushed
until like a certain set piece was built
or a certain
thing was done and it's just a totally
different way of working you've got to
get your mind around those
uh those things that you have to come
back to an episode so you're going to
have to keep all the episodes in your
head in a different way and figure out
okay wait i'm shooting this from
episodes
you know one when we're on episode eight
right now and where am i and how am i
what's our my dynamic with this
character that's changed over the season
um so it's challenging but also really
fun and exciting and also that the
stunt choreography and the that kind of
stuff is
takes a while to learn you can't just
say like hey we're going to do like a
five-page
fight scene tomorrow um
i did have to learn another language in
a week
but other than that i got a lot of time
uh i already have to stop i'm just gonna
say that i
am really looking forward to seeing the
dynamic between your two characters
as season two plays out thank you so
much it's a roller coaster so i hope you
enjoy it
cannot wait you guys have a great day
cheers